from the outset of your arrival into the
lands between you are directed by the
light of grace to stormville castle to
fight and overcome the first shard
bearer of the game godric be grafted but
before you can reach him before you can
even enter the castle you are met with
one of the most interesting sympathetic
and imposing characters in the game
standing in your path is the first real
boss of eldon ring margat the fel omen
when we first come across market we know
next to nothing about him he is someone
who looks down untarnished and sees our
search for the elden ring as
contemptible vowing to be the one to
extinguish our flame of ambition he
stands as an obstacle to be overcome
without much more significance
but we can learn a bit more about him
even this early in the game if we
acquire an item from patches
the item marget's shackle provides some
background a fetish bathed in golden
magic shackles were used to bind the
accursed people called the omen and
these ones were made to keep a
particular omen under strictest
confinement though faint the shackles
still retain vestiges of power enough to
trap the once-bound market on earth if
only for a short time here we have the
first inkling of margate's background as
a member of the cursed race of omen and
he is a special omen at that who is kept
under the strictest level of
imprisonment but as for why he stands in
our path or his motive for so actively
wishing to squash us we know not when he
falls he does not drop any item of
insight just a talisman pouch but his
fading dialogue is of interest
of the night
the hands of the fell oman shall brook
thee no quarter
ominous to say the least it sounds like
margaret is not done with us and may not
be dead which is something a keem player
may have noticed by the overall
importance his design seems to exude he
just seems too important to be simple
fodder before the godric fight
the rest of the message about the hands
of the fel omen is likely to be
forgotten by a player on their first
playthrough i remember thinking how
poetic the language was and then
promptly forgetting it the rest of the
game which is fair because we don't get
an actual explanation of what it means
until a late game area where an armor
set reveals the so-called hands of the
fel omen are actually the knight's
cavalry
their set reads
the knights cavalry who now wander the
dim roads at night were once led by the
fel omen and were deliverers of death
for great warriors knights and champions
here is our second insight into this
special omen he led the menacing band of
black knights to defeat and deliver
death to great foes the story of our
simple first game boss inches deeper and
deeper as we make our way towards the
capital more of the story unravels the
sword's monument near the outer wall
battleground grace tells the historic
tale of the second defense of lane del
the fel omen stacks high the corpses of
heroes yet the urge tree remains
unshaken
another testament to the might and
ferocity of margat he is once again
described as defeating scores of not
just random nobodies but heroes stacking
their corpses high
all in successful defense of the erd
tree and its capital city landell
perhaps this is the scene we see in the
opening cinematic where marget is seen
crushing a red-haired soldier the
voluminous red locks are evocative of
radon and the gauntlets match perhaps a
young radon took part in an attack on
the capital only to be halted by the fel
omen
and as we the tarnished make our way to
the golden city we learn that the fel
omen is not yet defeated a golden urgery
sigil erupts at the feet of a commoner
which then transforms into market he
again insults us in familiar fashion
little tarnished wretched flame of
ambition all that good stuff
once defeated he falls in a puff of
golden smoke dropping the viridian amber
medallion a precious jewel which houses
primordial life energy again we learn
little his fight here only confirms his
dedication to protecting the capital and
the erd tree
once we actually reach the inner city
the omen's story really begins to unfold
the surface of the urgery capital may be
golden and glorious but below it resides
a sinister darkness
under the city lies the subterranean
shunning grounds the forest residence of
the omen the race referred to by
margaret's shackle
these beings are cursed with horns and
growths born outside of grace
so the powers that be forced them into
the sewers to suffer out of sight out of
mind
the omen baron a doll of an omen child
tells a bit of their story it reads omen
babies have all their horns excised
causing most to perish these fetishes
are made to memorialize them
it concludes with one of the child's
cries
please don't hate me or curse me
please
even their weapons attest to their
subjugation their cleaver reads the
pattern etched upon the blade is the
remnant of a deteriorating malediction
or curse
indeed when bestowing a weapon
preparations must be made for taking it
away the order used the omen for their
strength but all the while kept them
downtrodden and enslaved after all the
order also had omen killers in its ranks
men who hunted the omen and who wore
masks carved with the image of evil
spirits that haunt the omen in their
nightmares the order never relented
their enslavement of the omen never
giving them an ounce of hope the omen
were or rather are truly tortured beings
with such a harsh existence bestowed
upon their kind it's a wonder that
margate defends the order and its city
with such passion
to learn why this is the case we must
ascend from landel's subterranean sewers
to its highest heights to the entrance
of the erd tree where we can expect to
find the lord of landel morgot the grace
given
rising up from staircase to branch past
the visage of godfrey and the black
knight assassin at the queen's
bedchamber we enter the court of the
elden throne and we are greeted by a
familiar voice
graceless tarnished
and at last we learned the true
significance of margaret the fel omen
that he is no one but a secret identity
of morgot the omen king the veiled
monarch the grace given morgot calls out
the other shard bearers who used to have
seats in this court he names them
traitors oh
since the shattering they have waged war
and only morgot has stayed to defend
landel and the urgery but in a world
where omen are cursed and omen killers
are soldiers of the order the king of
langdale could never be known to be an
omen so he fought as margaret the fell
while secretly acting as lane dell's
ruler as a mysterious figure seen by no
one that is why gideon ofnier calls him
the veiled monarch he never lets himself
be seen in the role of king he is only
ever visible when acting in the role of
margaret the omen
morgot stands in our way believing
tarnish to be unable to repair the elden
ring in this fight we see his true power
he shatters the covering of his sword
which is actually his accursed omen
blood that he had previously recanted
it's his true power that he has been
holding back and during the second phase
of the fight he rebukes us for forcing
him to use the rest of his curse's power
which fills the arena and stains the
circle of golden thrones
thy part in this
shall not be forgiven
nowhere better than here do we see the
conflicting personal identity of morgue
he is a son of queen america and godfrey
first elden lord but he was born as an
omen his royal blood could not overrule
his curse at birth and like all other
omen he was locked away
but unlike the others he was still
royalty after all and a demigod at that
his horns were not removed we learn
about his peculiar case from the regal
omen baron which reads omen babies born
of royalty do not have their horns
excise but instead are kept underground
unbeknownst to anyone imprisoned for
eternity
they are not mutilated just locked away
forever maybe retaining the horns gives
them some access to latent power found
in the omen blood
we know morgot was locked away from what
we read in his shackle which does work
against him in this fight too but at
some point he was able to break free
from his imprisonment and amazingly did
not enact revenge on those that sealed
him away instead he fought for the order
and became the most ardent defender of
those that would have kept him chained
in a dungeon through his many defenses
of the erd tree and its order morgot
earned the title grace given despite
being born without grace he earned
worthiness in the eyes of the golden
order
and as we defeat morgot we realize yet
another layer of his selfless action
morgot's dying breaths reveal that he
fought and defended the erd tree even
with no hope in sight
but a four
the tree wards off all who dana approach
we are
we are
all
forsaken
none may claim the title of elder lord
i
deeds shall be met with
failure
just as i
morgot knows no way to fix things to
repair what is broken to correct the
shattering
we as tarnished may go on to burn the
urge tree to remove its thorns and
access its interior but morgot either
did not know that this was possible or
could never bring himself to commit such
a cardinal sin committed to the order as
he was
despite believing he had failed he still
fought on and defended the urge tree to
his dying breath
and many times over morgot proved his
worth as margaret the fell he defeated
scores of heroes and led the knight's
cavalry in defense of the order he
intercepted the tarnished at stormville
and before us at least prevented their
meeting with godric at once both
protecting godric's great rune from
being taken and preventing godric from
growing stronger by grafting more
tarnish he defended landel ceaselessly
earning grace despite his cursed birth
his rune attests to this fact reading
this great rune is the anchor ring that
houses the base and proves two things
that the omen king was born of the
golden lineage and that he was indeed
the lord of lane del
and even during all of this he defended
the entrance to the three fingers with a
seal guarding the urge tree and world
from being burned and destroyed by the
frenzied flame
morgot could have righteously turned
bitter and rebelled against the world
that shunned and imprisoned him like his
twin moog he could have become
infatuated with his cursed blood and
been consumed by a lust for power
wishing to wipe away this unjust world
that would have been fair for him to do
it would have been understandable
instead he chose to try to better the
world he saw he became defender of what
he viewed as the source of life in the
lands between
in the end he could not fix the broken
world nor did he write the injustice
that plagued the land and the people of
his blood perhaps the path he took was
destined never to offer him these
opportunities to actually better the
land
but he found something to fight for and
he committed himself fully to it while
the other demigods fought each other and
marred the lands between morgot stood
steadfast in his protection maybe if
more stood with him a better outcome
could have been found but that was not
the case
from a prison sewer to lord of landel
morgot rose he was not given justice he
was not given love instead hardship was
his only birthright but even then he
still found a way a forlorn path to call
his
in the end his remembrance tells his
story
though born one of the graceless omen
morgot took it upon himself to become
the earth tree's protector he loved not
in return for he was never loved but
nevertheless
love it he did
there is more to discuss of the omen the
dung eater the age of despair ending and
of course morgot's interesting twin moog
lord of blood if you want to see more of
this lore explored consider subscribing
to the channel it lets me know that
people want to see more and it will keep
you abreast with my newest uploads with
that i hope you enjoyed and feel free to
leave a comment about what you thought
of morgot's story thanks for watching
bye
you